The one who is the true light, who gives light
to everyone was coming into the world,
he was in the world and the world was made through him.
But who was this light?
He was and is God with us?
So let me explain.
Had somebody asked me if I lost my
fantasy football league or something?
No, actually won mine.
Um, so our family life team
last week had a Christmas party
with all the volunteers or students and kids.
Everybody works with them. And they had a contest
called an ugly Sweater Decorating Contest where the prize
for the winning team was
that I wear it on this Sunday before Christmas.
So yeah, here we are.
Uh, they had to incorporate the table number
that they were sitting at as well.
So on the ninth day of Christmas,
we had nine elders praying.
So yeah, uh, if you're new here,
it's not always like this, okay?
Uh, I do normally wear a Christmas suit on Sunday
before Christmas.
But um, let's just say we don't take ourselves
very seriously around here.
We take Jesus very seriously, but we can laugh
and have a good time along the way towards that end, okay?
So, uh, if you, well by the way,
I just hope I don't turn into forkey, uh,
where things just start falling off as I'm preaching.
Like, 'cause this has already been some things lost.
So just, we'll just move on. All right?
Anyway, if you're not already there,
take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me to the book of John, the gospel
of John chapter one.
As we're working through this month,
we've been focused on the biblical word,
Emmanuel, what we just saying?
That idea that God is with us, that word looks at
who he is and we've been building that idea as we go
through this journey in John chapter one.
But who is this God who came to be with us?
Who is the God who gives life the word
that gives life the word
that shines a light into the darkness?
Who is that? The one who came to save? Who actually is that?
Well, this last section of the introduction of John
verses one through 18, it it culminates
this last section verses 14
through 18 culminates the description of Jesus,
this God the Son taken on flesh.
We saw that he is now not only life, he is not only light.
What we'll see today is that he is also grace and truth.
He is grace and truth.
And so I'm gonna read the whole section verses one
through 18 we've been building to this point
where eternity past leads to
what we saw him do back then.
What did he do when he shows up?
Look at what these 18 verses teach us about God.
In the beginning was the word and the word was with God
and the word was God.
He was in the beginning with God.
All things were made through him.
And without him was not anything made that was made
in him was life and the life was the light of men.
The light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it.
There was a man sent from God whose name was John.
He came as a witness to bear witness about the light
that all might believe through him.
He was not the light,
but he came to bear witness about the light,
the true light which gives light
to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
Yet the world did not know him.
He came to his own and his own people did not receive him,
but to all who did receive him, who believed in his name,
he gave the right to become children of God
who were born not of blood, nor of the will of the flesh,
nor of the will of man, but born of God.
And the word became flesh and dwelt among us.
And we have seen His glory, glory as
of the only son from the Father full of grace and truth.
John bore witness about him and cried out.
This was he of whom I said, he who comes after me, ranks
before me because he was before me.
For from his fullness, we have all received grace upon grace
for the law was given through Moses.
Grace and truth came through Jesus Christ.
No one has ever seen God, the only God
who is at the father's side.
He has made him known God.
This is your beautiful powerful word
showing us about the word God, the Son.
Jesus made flesh. And so God, give us a picture today.
I pray that our hearts would be stirred in
affection for you.
That we would realize
that this is not just business as usual.
Christmas is not just sentimentality.
Christmas means you, God came to be known
and we would recognize and believe
and worship you with everything we are as a result of that.
Show us today, God, what you want us to know and believe
and act upon for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen.
So when you're reading the Bible, one solid principle of how
to interpret the Bible is to look for repeated words.
And you see that a couple times here.
It tends to show an emphasis on
what God's spirit is wanting us to know and recognize
and understand here.
Well we zoom in
to these five verses specifically we see a word repeated
two times in verse 14.
It's implied in a few other spots, but,
but verse 14 has it twice.
It's the word glory, which in the original Greek language
you see that word on the screen.
The the word is dsa and that word means fame or recognition
or prestige or giving honor to someone
or something enhancing the honor.
You might have heard the big word doxology.
Uh, it's a similar word used in in uh, the church a lot
where it's the study of worship, the practice of worship
where we're giving honor to the Lord, we're glorifying God.
That's doxology coming from that word, doxa,
which is glory right here.
But that that concept's not just repeated in verse 14,
twice it even shows up.
Verse 15, John talks about the ranking of this word
that he's been talking about the whole time.
Then verse 18, John talks about the only God.
That's a phrase that's often tied with God's glory.
And so we'll get to some other repeated words in a moment.
But the thread running
through the section here is clearly the notion of glory,
glory that's tied to the word
that he's been talking about since verse one,
the word and glory.
So each of our points today is gonna fill out this
picture of glory.
It'll teach us about God, who he is and what he's done.
And first we start right off in verse 14, with
that glory incarnate, glory incarnate.
You again may not understand that word, but just look at it.
You carnivore, you've heard that
before of flesh eaters, uh, that's talking about body
and so incarnate in fleshed
the word became flesh.
Look at that again. Verse 14, just the first part
and the word, that same word from verse one became flesh
and dwelt among us.
The word God that we've seen already became flesh.
Only five words yet packed with meaning.
And John intentionally said it this way to counteract one
of the dominant heresies At the time there was a heresy
that said that the physical body itself was bad.
Spiritual things are good. The physical body,
you need to be freed from it.
And what does John do here?
John pictures God's view of the body here
by saying the body is a key part of you as a person.
It itself also needs to be redeemed,
not just your spiritual side.
If Jesus didn't need, if if, if God didn't need
to redeem the body, Jesus would've just come
as some kind of spirit form.
But he came as a body.
He came in a body and and here's the truth.
This might be a little bit of a a
difference than you've heard before.
He didn't just enter into a man's body
that was another heresy at the time.
It says clearly he took on flesh,
meaning he added a human nature already to his divine nature
so that he could dwell among us.
And that word for dwelt is really an interesting word here
because it's the same word used in the Old Testament
for the word tabernacle.
That was God's dwelling place among his people
as they wandered through the wilderness.
And once they even planted in the land,
it was God's dwelling place.
So the word literally added on a human nature.
He became flesh.
He tabernacled among us
to bring his presence to his people.
That's the whole meaning of Christmas.
By the way, see, God the Son
took on flesh and became a baby born in Bethlehem.
That's what we mean when we say glory talking about God.
Glory incarnate,
glory made flesh the incarnation
and that's what we have seen.
We couldn't see it otherwise, but that's what it says.
We have seen His glory as a result of the incarnation,
which is the next piece here about this glory.
We see glory incarnate, but then we see glory revealed.
This glory has been revealed
to us again.
Verse 14, watch this and the word became flesh
and dwelt among us and we have seen His glory.
Glory as of the only son
or the only begotten you might say from the Father full
of grace and truth.
This is Trinitarian language all over this,
but it's not the first time.
It's not the only time John 17 five,
Jesus himself is praying to the Father.
He says, glorify me in your own presence
with the glory I had with you before the world existed.
So the Father and the Son, I know it's complicated,
but Jesus himself understood this, that the glory is part
of just being God.
And it says here in verse 14, we've seen the glory of God.
Well how did we see it? Well, it's by the word
becoming flesh and dwelling among us.
We see the glory of God through Jesus Christ himself.
And here's why this is so important
because Romans one says there are aspects about God
that we can learn through creation,
that we can understand a little bit about
who God is on its own creation itself.
De declares the glory of God,
but we cannot know his character
just by looking at creation.
See, unless God showed us
who he is, we wouldn't understand.
We wouldn't fully understand who God is
and understand his glory.
He had to create a way for us to understand.
He had to know how we, we had to know
through some way we could understand And what does it say?
We learn about this glory, this glory revealed.
What do we learn about it? It says He's full of grace
and truth, right?
He said that at in verse 14, full of grace and truth.
Those are also words repeated in this section.
If you notice that grace is said, uh, truth is said twice,
but grace is used four times in just these five verses.
So again, repeated words mean we should pay attention.
In fact, look again at verse 16, how
that verse talks about grace.
It says for from his the word become flesh
from his fullness.
We have all received grace upon grace.
Isn't that interesting that word for fullness,
it means something like the sum total
or everything it ever could be.
All that it brings with it it it's there.
And the word here is the fullness, the fullness of the word.
It says distributes things here.
Good gifts like grace,
like when the word specifically when the word was revealed,
the fullness of the word,
his fullness brought us grace, right?
So the fullness of grace, that is the glory revealed the
fullness of grace came with him.
Look at that phrase again at the end of verse 16.
Here's how my translation says it, grace upon grace,
maybe your translation says something different, but
but grace upon grace, what?
What that means is that grace replaces grace.
You kinda layering it like a cake.
Grace upon grace, upon grace, upon grace.
Maybe yours says grace, for grace.
That means if you would take one of them away, you get this.
Well, it's the same thing.
You take grace away, you get grace.
It's just repeated over and over. I love this translation.
One gracious blessing after another.
And so you see what this is saying to us, right?
When the word the glory revealed himself,
the fullness he brought was grace upon grace,
upon grace, upon grace.
This is not just a New Testament principle.
Listen to this in the Old Testament, Lamentations 3 22
and 23 says the steadfast love, that's the covenant love
of the Lord never ceases.
His mercies never come to an end.
They are new every morning.
Great is your faithfulness like
that sun comes up every morning, day upon day upon day,
grace upon grace in the Old Testament,
mercy upon mercy upon mercy every day.
That's the truth of the fullness.
Bringing with it the glory of God revealed in Christ
means we received the fullness of grace when he showed up.
It's like a bubbling spring, right?
An infinite spring of grace just constantly bubbling up
and bubbling up and bubbling up.
Or you might think in this time of the year,
you might think it's like an escalator where
that star just keeps coming and coming
and coming and coming, right?
It just keeps going. It never ends.
The sum total of all the grace
that there ever could be is found in Jesus Christ.
The glory revealed the fullness of grace.
We get grace upon grace. Why is that?
Because he himself is full of grace.
He is grace itself.
I mean, just think about a, a wet sponge.
When you squeeze a wet sponge, what comes out of it?
I know I heard water. If water's in the sponge right,
you could fill it with Kool-Aid
and it comes out Kool-Aid, right?
That's the idea. Whatever is inside of it,
whatever it's full of, you squeeze it, it comes out
the fullness of grace.
Jesus being full of grace means it just flows out of him
from his fullness.
We have received grace upon grace.
That means there's no limit no matter
what you have done.
There's no limit grace upon grace upon grace,
but that glory revealed it wasn't just full of grace, right?
Did you see it? Verse 14 says, he is full
of grace and truth.
Verse 17, grace and truth came through Jesus Christ.
And so he's the fullness of grace
and he is the fullness of truth.
So the glory revealed brought grace
and truth in its fullness.
Now that word truth here means the content of what is true.
And we kind of understand that inherently not true based on
what you or I think about the situation,
but true based on the standard of truth, Jesus,
which he himself said in John 14, six, Jesus said,
I am the way, the truth and the life, right?
The truth, not just I have truth, I am full of truth.
I am the truth
in its fullness.
But what does that even mean?
Like we talk about that we amen it. We believe it. Yeah.
Okay, but what does that even mean?
Of course, fullness of truth means his commands
and we need to obey his commands and that's good for us.
Yes, but here's how we hone in on something for us today.
If Jesus is the fullness of truth, then
that means everything in our lives is to be measured by him.
If he's the standard, everything in our lives must be
measured by him.
How he lived, how he spoke, how he responded,
how he loved should be us too,
should be the way we do it measured by his standard.
See, love is not measured by the standard of the world.
Love is how Jesus exemplified it,
how he loved even his enemies.
So, so we can think we're loving,
but if we're not loving like Jesus,
we're not hitting the standard of truth.
Generosity is not measured compared to the standard
of those people around us and how generous they are
or we are or not.
Generosity is how Jesus did it
where he gave his very life for others.
Purity. Purity's not measured based on how, how,
how you're bad or worse
or better than someone else around you.
It's not comparative to anyone else.
Purity is how Jesus did it.
Who by the way lived a perfect life, never sinning once.
Jesus is the standard. He's the fullness of truth.
He's the fullness of grace. He's the fullness of truth.
And so when the glory of God revealed himself
as the only son from the Father, what we now see
and understand is what grace
and truth actually look like in Jesus.
The glory revealed shows us us rather than their ideas
that we kind of understand in our heads.
We see grace and truth in its fullness in Jesus Christ.
And that's why this glory is supreme.
That's why this glory incarnate, this glory revealed.
This glory is supreme over all other
potential competitors.
Which by the way is something even John the
Baptist understood.
You remember who he was, right?
He was the Old Testament prophet Elijah like figure
who was sent by God to prepare the way for the Messiah
to ready the, the pathway that that they would see
and understand who the Messiah was coming to be.
And many and many people thought he was the Messiah.
He told them, no, I'm not. I'm just pointing to the Messiah.
But he was someone,
Jesus himself called the greatest man ever born of a woman.
And so John is a a big time figure.
But did you see what verse 15 records about John the Baptist
claiming about Jesus?
Look at it again. Verse 15, John bore witness about him
and cried out this was he of whom I said, he who comes
after me, ranks before me
because he was before me.
Now, there's a couple things going on here.
I'll explain what he means there.
First John, the Baptist's perspective was that the glory
of Jesus was greater than any other
glory anywhere else.
See, there's a lot of talk about rankings right now
who ranks above whom?
Who, who deserves to be here
versus who deserves to be there.
They shouldn't have made it, they shouldn't make it.
All of these. It's a lot of ranking talk.
But John the Baptist knew where he stood.
Jesus, John later said this about Jesus, I'm unworthy
to even untie his sandal.
The illustration of being on your face
before someone touching the dirtiest part of their body.
He's like, I can't even do that.
I'm not even worthy to get close to him in that way.
He also understood in chapter
three, he's talking about Jesus.
He says, man, I must decrease, but Jesus must increase.
And then he said this. He said, he who comes from above is
above all John this,
this hu, this humble man gazing upon the glory
of God in Jesus Christ.
He recognized where he stood
because he recognized the glory of God found in Jesus.
And so he knew the ranking,
but he also understood something else.
Second, John understood that Jesus was God in the flesh.
He knew it. He knew it from before he even met Jesus.
'cause remember what verse 15 said?
He who comes after me, ranks before me
because he was before me.
He's talking about Jesus's preexistence as God,
that Jesus wasn't born like he was born.
Jesus was born as a man taking on flesh, God
becoming a man.
Because in the timeline, if you know your story
around Christmas, John the Baptist was actually born
first with Elizabeth.
He was born a couple months ahead of when Jesus was born.
But here, John clearly says, Jesus existed before I did.
I was created. Jesus was not created.
God the Son was not created.
Which points us back to verse one.
Remember this in the beginning was the word.
He was already there. The word was with God
and the word was God.
John knew Jesus was God the Son.
So glory incarnate,
glory revealed it certainly was supreme over John
Glory, over John Supreme, over John again, as great
as John the Baptist was this giant of a man
who Jesus looked at and said was great.
As faithful as John was, there was zero comparison
between John and Jesus.
The glory of God and Jesus was supreme over
anything John brought to the table.
But we also see something else here in verse 17.
This glory was superior also over Moses.
Over Moses two.
Look at verses 16
and 17 again, for from his fullness,
we have all received grace upon grace
for the law was given through Moses.
Grace and truth came through Jesus Christ.
John, notice what he does.
He compares the incarnation of Jesus with the giving
of the law in the Old Testament that both in a way
where God revealing himself to his people.
Now we often on our side of this
we'll pit those two things against each other like, ah,
we're not law people anymore.
We're Jesus people and we'll think they're in opposition.
We forget when we do that.
We forget that God's giving
of the law was actually a measure of his grace too, right?
You ever thought about it that way?
Because remember when God freed his people from slavery in
Egypt, he graciously gave them a covenant by which they were
to live so they would do well in the promised land
and so that they would reflect his goodness
to a watching world around them.
The law was good to lead them towards those things.
It reflected the character of God to them.
They wouldn't have known otherwise how good God was.
But he told them, he showed them.
He gave them his words so that they could know him.
It was good. The law was good,
but it was still law and commandments, right?
That's why Jesus coming full of truth and grace.
Grace upon grace He came in that that's why
that's such good news.
If we only had law, it's good, but it's not good news.
Jesus is truth, absolutely,
but he, he does that in a gracious way.
He is truth. He does it in an undeservedly kind way
because when Jesus is the truth,
you go read the New Testament.
There are some times that Jesus is really firm
in teaching the truth to people who need it to hear it.
Matthew five, in the Sermon on the Mount
where Jesus is talking about,
you guys hear it this way, that this is sin.
I actually take it a whole lot farther
and I go to your heart and say,
this is actually the sin root of that one sin.
So he's firm, he he's really firm in
the truth as he taught people how to live.
He's saying, here's the standard, it's me.
It's not what everybody else says it's me.
But in that he in grace
showed God's compassion and love toward broken
and sinful people like you
and me all over the place, those
who needed God's forgiveness, he said, here's grace,
here's love, here's forgiveness.
But again, don't pit it against the law
because remember in the law, God made a way for you
to be forgiven through sacrificial systems that he set up.
There was still grace,
there was law, but there was still grace.
It's just that now in its fullness,
you see it in Jesus, you see grace,
you see truth exemplified shown
and given grace upon grace through Jesus
because what the law could never do,
Jesus came to do that.
Listen to this in Romans chapter eight it says,
for God has done what the law weakened
by the flesh could not do
by sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh for sin.
He condemned sin in the flesh in order
that the righteous requirement
of the law might be fulfilled in us who walk not according
to the flesh but according to the spirit.
That's why this glory revealed in God, the Son,
the flesh He took on that glory.
That's why that is supreme over every other glory
because that's the only way we could actually be saved.
The law is good. The law has grace, but it cannot save us.
It's only through the God man, Jesus satisfying the demands
of that law and then dying on the cross for us
and the penalty of that sin in our lives.
It's the only way that's grace because we don't deserve it.
His glory, supreme seen in grace and truth
and notice this, everything I've said so far,
God did all of that so
that his glory could be known.
He did everything chapter one says, so that
his glory could be known,
not just hinted at not just suspected,
but actually known, not just known about.
We know about God's glory,
actually known His glory can be known because listen, if you
and I in our sin would see God in all
of his fullness, we would die.
No one can see God and live because we're sinful. He's not.
He's holy, he's glorious. We would die.
Even Moses on Sinai, the mountain
that God invited him up to to say, come meet with me.
Even on the mountain, Moses says, God,
I wanna see your glory.
And God's like, Hey, hold up.
Uh, I'm gonna put you in this cave
and I'm just gonna let you see the very last
glimmer of my robe.
'cause he knew Moses couldn't handle it.
Moses could not see God and live
because of Moses being human, sinful
and God being glorious and holy.
Yet in that same scene where Moses is involved
with God's glory, God reveals his character to Moses
that in his fullness, he's merciful,
he's gracious, he is slow to anger, abounding
and steadfast love and faithfulness.
And so what we get a picture of here is
what God was doing is saying, here's a glimpse of my glory.
Here's a little sliver of my glory.
Yeah, you see this part of my robe, but here's who I am.
Here's who I am. My words are telling you who I am.
My glory is this is, this is this,
but here's where this matters in John one 18, what
that shows us is that in Jesus Christ,
in the word becoming flesh, we get a more full revelation
of God's glory as God.
The Son makes him known like we'll hear it,
we'll hear it, we'll read it, we'll understand it.
We get a glimpse of God through his word.
But what we actually see in Jesus since he actually is God,
is that in him, he reveals God to us in ways
that no other revelation can reveal.
Just think about this. God's word in the Old
Testament was mediated through prophets
like they spoke on behalf of God.
Nobody got God's word directly.
It was God's prophets speaking his word to people.
God's glory, even in that tabernacle was hidden
behind a curtain.
It was mediated through priests.
They had to go in there in a special way and
and kind of appease and go and sacrifice and come back out
and this carry back and forth.
They were priests mediating between the glory of God.
Nobody could go in besides the one man once a year, right?
That's the point. Those revelation
ways were limited.
Yet Jesus came so
that his people could experience the glory of God in full.
He came to say, I am God, I am the glory of God
revealed to you.
So we see God's glory in Jesus.
And then by the way, for us today, he plants his spirit
inside of us to dwell within us, not just to dwell with us
so that we have the glory of God within us now, all
because God the son
became flesh and dwelt among us so
that we could know him.
Otherwise, God stays over here.
We stay here, we're in trouble.
We might know about God, but we wouldn't know him
unless he makes the way for us to experience His glory
and to be transformed
as we gaze upon His glory.
Listen to what second Corinthians three says.
As Paul reflects on this idea, he says, we all
with unveiled face, meaning that veil
that separated us from God has been taken away.
Now we have access back and forth with the glory of God.
He says, we all with unveiled face, behold looking at,
staring at the glory of the Lord are being transformed
into the same image from one degree of glory to another.
Right? That's the unmediated glory of God.
Now we gaze and stare and look at it and reflect on it,
and he changes us into that kind
of image again
and and still remember church, listen at Christmas,
remember, God could have left us in our sin.
He could have abandoned us
because we turned our backs on him.
We said, we don't want anything to do with you.
We don't care. We could have been left in
that eternal deadness and darkness,
but he didn't because of his grace.
What did he do? He took on flesh to give us life,
to shine light into the darkness of our sin,
to be and flesh out grace
and truth, to save us, to make us more like Him.
That's why he came.
Just like Jesus prayed, John 17, he said,
this is eternal life that they know you,
the only true God and Jesus Christ whom you sent.
This is why he came so that we would be able,
sinners like you and me would be able
to know him in a way we never could on our own,
and so do you.
Do you know him? If you don't
turn from your sin and turn to him
and say, I believe Jesus I I believe in you,
and if you do believe, rejoice in him.
Rejoice in this glory incarnate.
This glory revealed this glory supreme over all things,
and may we live in the hope of that glory known
today, this week in
Christmas and every day.
That's the hope we have in the glory of God
seen in Jesus Christ.
Would you pray with me towards that end today
As we look at him, as we gaze upon his glory
revealed in His word,
in the word Jesus,
just reflect on that for a moment to say
and ask yourself, what does that belief mean to me?
What does that mean? Belief mean? Do you believe?
Have you seen God like this?
Listen, if he's been just a buddy on a shelf
that you pull down whenever you need him, but
otherwise he has nothing to do with your life, then
that is wrong.
The glory of God revealed in Jesus means he is.
Everything should be everything to us.
Maybe that means this Christmas looks a little different
to worship him, not just be sentimental about the holiday,
but to worship Him God with us
so that we would know him and glorify.
If you have some questions about that, come find one of us
after the service is done, just to be honest
and ask questions and love to help you with that.
This is our God.
Lord, we give you the glory.
You must increase, we must decrease.
The one who is from above is above all
you are before us.
You are higher than us
and so may we give you the glory that you are worthy of.
Thank you God. We don't deserve grace upon grace,
and yet you made the way you came to us to make us
more like you as we believe so God, give us
that faith we need today.
In Jesus' name, amen.